Now, I would love to welcome to
the stage both Alfredo and Anita.
Please join me in welcoming
both. Just tell us a little
bit about yourselves. Um,
and [inaudible] let's start with you.
Well, thank you for having us today.
My name is [inaudible] bias and I am
the program director of our advocacy and
mediation program at Robert F.
Kennedy Human Rights.
My name is Alfredo [inaudible]. I'm the
executive director of [inaudible] Salon.
Would you saw ng or human rights NGO
that works in Venezuela and we assist,
uh, pro bono, the big themes
of repression in Minnesota.
Great. Thank you. Um, I forgot
about through your work, um,
through your Human Rights
Organization for opener,
you've helped over
10,000 people. Um, I had,
I had outdated data. I, I thought
it was 40,000. It's actually 10,000,
which is incredible.
So you've helped over 10,000 people.
Can you tell us a little bit about your
work as it pertains to the restrictions
on freedom of expression?
Well,
yes.
We have assisted more than 10,000 people
because we've been working since 2002
actually, uh, we started,
um, oh, I started myself, uh,
assist in the family of one guy.
His name is Jesus,
actually was Jesus an 18 years old,
a boy who was killed.
He was shot in his head.
So at that time,
I thought there was going to be, you
know, my only case, I thought, okay,
I'm not going to cease this guy because
I'm, the family actually came to me.
I can tell you the whole story is
longer than that. But then after that,
a second family came to me and the
third one on the fourth one or whatever,
and I actually thought it was going to
end, uh, into southern too because, uh,
I,
I mean,
I wasn't used to assist the big
themes of a state repression.
This guy was actually
killed in a mass process.
Protests that happened in 2002.
Um,
well actually, repression
increased a lot. And,
um, so, uh,
this moment we have assisted more than
10,000 people or where I'm talking about
a big themes of a [inaudible]
including people that are,
he has been or be tried to taint, uh, um,
they're also forced,
disappeared. Basically. Uh,
people have been killed.
People that have been tortured,
so on the number has increased
a lot. How we help them, well,
we have sees them legally,
but it is legally many.
You've talk about illegality in Venezuela
over the judicial system is something
that is not a uh,
with,
I mean it is very important for the
world is very important and for us,
but for the Goldman index
actually controlled the
actually absolutely everything
to work as a lawyer is minimum of
percentage of the work that you do.
So actually we do
campaigns. We do, I mean,
a lot of different things in order
to increase the cost of repression,
that's actually what we do more
than assistant legally. Uh,
all these big themes of
repression. So, um, we,
you know, hug, I will say
the families and we, um,
held that we won, uh, and the
families or the friends or whatever,
even looking for people
that are being disappeared.
So that's actually what we do. But there
is a very important thing that we do. Uh,
and I realized, uh, that, that,
that was extremely important recently
that we registered all detainees on
victims of repression.
And you can imagine,
and then I realize that if we haven't
eve not meaning if we were in there and
Ray Easter and everything,
nobody will know how many people have
been detained or very important or where
they are. And, uh,
that's a very important thing that we are
doing right now besides, you know, well,
all things that we do with victims.
And
can you talk a little bit about,
um,
okay.
Basically how the organization
has reacted in the,
um, how assembly and
creating awareness, um,
due to technology. Um,
how has your organization,
um,
in the context of Association in Assembly
reacted in terms of
restrictions on that as well?
Well, we were live in a country
that everything's been controlled.
Um, um, freedom of expression.
I mean,
it doesn't exist as the,
as you know it here in the United
States and in free countries.
So we don't have like a new opportunity
to go to the media and talk about what
we do.
Actually,
that's something that happened until 2007,
there was a very important thing
that happened that they closed.
The government clothes are very
important to be channel. Uh,
the name was our,
our see TV and I'm telling
you about it because that,
that channel Lisa, I was able to go
and, and denounced what was going on.
And, um, all the situation
of what's going on, um,
are these moment is impossible.
I mean,
do you don't have a media that you
go and talk about what is going on?
And the media actually doesn't show
what is going on. Um, I mean, they,
they,
they doesn't show and somebody is detained
or when somebody is killed or when
somebody searchers something that we do,
we do it by ourselves. So what we do, uh,
in order to,
you know,
to continue working and showing people
what is going on and to increase
political cost where they use media for
our social media is extremely important.
Um, that's something that actually
I didn't know too much about it.
I started using social
media and to southern nine,
that was the first student
I actually helped. He,
he was the first student that was
actually, are we trying to tame his name?
Is Julio on? I remember
just to tell you an anecdote
about it. Um, he will listen.
He will stick into the court and the,
this guy who was at 21 years old at
the time, maybe 20, he was very Thien,
you know, very naive like, and, and, um,
he was at the doors of the court
and I took a picture of him,
uh, you know, and it wasn't
Twitter actually. So I,
I Polish it in Twitter. I didn't know too
much about Twitter at the time. And, um,
I used it and actually the picture,
I mean, the whole old Venezuelans,
it's just saw the picture
and they were all, you know,
reacting about this student.
It was taken to prison and he was
extremely important because, uh,
after that a hunger strike
started of the students,
um,
you know,
claiming for the release of the sky and
actually he was released in 22 days.
And, um, so that was very
important. After that we'll,
I'm being using social
media as, um, as the most,
I will say is most this,
the most important tool for
increasing the cost of repression.
Because it's not that you
can, you can tell it, uh, to,
to the world like easier because it's
not that you have the media there too.
I mean, the me story control, even they,
they controlling the by themselves
or because the government section put
pressure on them or they've Cobram and
just control the whole media because they
have all state, you know,
the public, uh, the,
the channels or though the media that's
being controlled by the government but
the state.
But,
so that's the way that we actually show
people where it's going on on the world.
So it is extremely important.
I mean the way how we can, um,
in some way work without,
without having freedom of
expression, you know, that the way,
at least as you know, how
you know, how it works. Yeah.
And you briefly touched on it a little
bit about your work with detainees and
alerting the families.
Can you talk a little bit about that,
what that looked like before your
work? What it looks like now? We work,
I always say that we work in
the darkness and solitude.
So because when there is a mass protest
and a lot of people are out there on the
streets and protesting, at least
you are, you know, with your family,
your friends and all of that. And
when we start working well, where,
when people are arbitrary that taint
after I did the protest and eh,
and because of a cause of repression.
So,
so we go what we do actually,
people in Minnesota knows followup,
they know for a panel and they know that
we help people that are being arbitrary
thing.
But more than that,
they know that they only way to know
where their son or daughter or mother or
father, Eh, ease, I mean was taken,
is to call for up in us.
So what we do, we have,
we are more than four and volunteers
right now. It's incredible. I mean,
he's a very big organization now when
these volunteers do is not just lawyers,
lawyers,
we are right now formed by more than
160 lawyers or around the country.
But what the balloon juice do, the
volunteers are the ones, I mean,
I'm talking to volunteers on a
student, a mother or whatever. I mean,
even volunteers are, we're already
big of repression in some polling.
So they help for helping other victims.
Um,
so they go, because when you're
detained, technically in Venezuela,
you are forced,
disappeared.
I mean your [inaudible] they're
forced disappearances so why?
Because you didn't know
where you being taken.
It's not that you call 800 government
Bhavana soil and then you find out who,
who, where, where your, your son
is being detained or your daughter.
So that's what we do actually.
We work at night, uh,
until the morning in order to
know where these new know where,
where the people that they need are.
So the families are sold,
the feminist called us and we tell
the family go to the, to that place.
So because we have found out
that these guys send that place.
So whenever we found
out, for example, Pedro,
he's in whatever place
and how we find it out.
Well because we talked to the,
to the custodians there and you know,
he's not like an official thing.
And so we do it like underground.
So we talked to them, this,
that, these guy here, whatever.
So then when you find out
that these guys there,
because somebody tells you
that he, these guys, they're,
sometimes you find out
that there are 10 others.
So we start helping these people.
So we tell the families on,
we use Twitter basically or
the social media to tell gay,
these guy has been detained in this place.
So the families called also in come to
the place and they know where they are.
So, and then you know, the
whole process started. So they,
some of them I've taken to
the course room, they are not,
but it's more important that because
you have to provide food to these people
because these people is not that you're
being detained and you have food and
water.
I mean you don't have it.
Even food and water if you
are not detained so that you
can imagine in Venezuela.
So you can imagine if, how
if you are detained, I mean
you have to provide water.
So you have to bring water, you
have to bring food, you have to um,
general bring everything to these
people that are being detained. So,
but he's extremely important
because as I said before,
you imagine if we were in there,
I mean,
nobody will know where the detainees are.
So I'm going to talking
just since 2014 January,
2014 they are being exactly till today,
11,903 people that have been Abby
triple detained for political reasons.
So,
and we have a race third now we
have a very sophisticated database.
So we have register everything, the
place where they, where the Tane the age,
the profession. I mean we know everything.
How many women have you detained?
So this is a very confidential
information, but you have
absolutely everything.
So it's not that we,
when I said that there had been
more than 10,000 detainees,
11,000, 903, it's not because
I'm, the media tells me, well,
the media gets information from
what we tell them where we have.
So, oh, this is some of the
things that we do. And um, oh,
some of the things that we actually,
we have our car,
I kind of a mathematical way of analyzing
and the actions that we have to do in
order to increase the political costs.
It's a kind of interest in thing. Um,
because we, we, we use like
a tactical plan. I mean it's,
it's not something that we do at
right now. Like I'm like, you know,
as an informal way,
we do it in a very tactical way of,
you know, doing a specific thing.
So we analyze it and all of that.
And I'm telling you this because I was,
I was telling you about
the legal assistance,
actually the,
the,
the number of actions that we have
in order to release a person is,
Eh, is for reactions. 40.
So the legal assistant is just
one of the 40 actions of the cell.
So there are many. So, and
social media, he counts. Um,
the value for social media
is five of the 40 actions.
It's that kind of, I mean, it's the berry
a methodology that longer too. I mean,
there's that long explanation,
but that's how we work.
And why have you chosen to become a human
rights defender when it comes at such
a great rest of your life and your safety?
I didn't choose to become
our humorous offender.
I mean the two of these,
it will sound,
I don't know how we'll sell,
but at the beginning I was
graduated from Catholic University,
good university in Venezuela,
g-suite university in by the you suits.
And um,
and then I came to Georgetown University
and I got my master's degree in Latin
American stories from the
School of Foreign Service.
And then I went to London School of
Economics and I got my master's degree in
banking law.
So I care about human rights
and is not that id didn't care.
I didn't know anything about the
human race that even start humor.
It's what happens. What are the,
was telling before that in 2002,
one guy was skill, he's was shouting, he
said 18 years old boy, his name was Jesus.
He's mother name was Maria.
So,
um,
and I was at that time and a dicer
to the Supreme Court of Justice,
um, to the Constitutional
Chamber of the Supreme Court.
And I was working as a corporate lawyer
is still work as a corporate lawyer with
all the restrictions and all
of that. Um, so as, so I said,
I saw this site did to help this guy.
That's it.
I thought that a fight,
you know, help the sky,
then I will, it will finish and
I will continue with my work.
But then I realized, and for
example, there was a, um,
right now my,
my friend and member of that my NGO and
also part of the vote of the extras go
salary meal who is also my compadre like
and uh,
we started helping these people
and actually we realized that no,
there was known NGOs doing
legal assistance pro bono
to these people because I
realized, I thought that there were
a lot of NGOs hoping these people.
So I thought, okay, we'll help this guy
and then our NGO will come to us and,
and continue with, uh, with
assistance as a of these people.
But actually there was his sous,
then there was another okay.
Schools, John Carlos and you know, and
now we have Geraldine, we have Maria,
we have all these people
that actually were,
became super pressured and they
came to us and ask for help.
And,
um,
yeah,
I became a humorous offender and actually
in 2002 I thought it was the end.
MMM.
It's just on three.
I thought he was the end and do
something and for it was the end.
And now we're in 2017 and we are still,
um,
helping all these people
are being tortured like, uh,
with electric shocks or um,
you know,
sexually abused or were killed. Uh, like,
um, you know, I can, I
can tell you many names.
They are already the families
of these people already.
No, no, no. Just my friends,
they are part of the follow up in a
family of my NGO family because they had
become part or photo banana and they
are not just my friends or my family.
And
uh,
you know, a, a very
interesting thing that we,
when you start helping people,
you'd never know. I mean,
you didn't want to do it of course.
Okay.
But then you feel like a
need of helping another one.
And when you listen to them and they
tell you their story about what is
happening to them and more,
most of these people are very poor people,
so they don't have low, I mean that
they have money to pay for a lawyer.
If they would have money,
they of course,
they didn't call those a to
pay for a lawyer. So, um,
so you're getting to do,
get involved with all these people.
And when a mother of, for
example, Carter, Julio Velasco,
an 18 years old boy student
who's right now in jail,
and he has to be, um,
you know, he's sick, uh,
and all of that, and he's there in
jail and his mother took to you and,
and, and crying and then
you get involved with it.
So it come to be a human rights
defender and to help people,
he had become an addiction.
To me. It's true. I mean,
it's like an addiction. So I,
I, I always, sometimes
I wake up, I said, okay,
I have to finish with it because
I'm very tired. Because as I said,
I work in the mornings,
I mean,
very late at night. And, uh,
I came to my house sometimes
at 4:00 AM for example,
because somebody called me
that he was being detained.
And so I go to the prison
center to the military,
uh, you know, place where they are being
detained or the police station, whatever.
And uh, and then the next
day I said, I'm very tired,
so I have to continue with my work,
with my regular work or have to, you
know, continue musician also, sorry,
I need to play music or things.
And I,
and I realized after I slipped a
little bit a wake up and again, I said,
okay, I have to continue because
these people asking for help.
So in the end is not that daddy's
real sacrifice because if you were a
sacrifice,
I'm told sure that I will stop doing
it is actually a great benefit.
And I'm,
maybe I'm talking too much,
but I will tell you another little thing.
We have four principals in a migraine
section or what they call the four C's
versus the forces because the, the, the,
the words to start with a c in Spanish,
it's Constantia, which means perseverance.
The second one is compromised,
which means commitment.
The third one is [inaudible]
would you means conviction.
And the fourth one and the most important
one is quarter sawn, which means heart.
This is very important one because
I is not just a beautiful words,
the it has a meaning
but that everyone but,
and I explained to everyone
whereas the meaning,
but the last one is very important
because w I explained it and he said what
means Corazon are hard. It's not just love
of romantic word, it's more than that.
That when you two good things to people,
you will receive good things to you.
I'm actually,
I'm very happy doing what I'm
doing and I have a great family,
a lot, a lovely flat, lovely family,
a nice songs on and they
appreciate what I do.
And this is just,
the family is very important
for me but have very well be.
So ward term receiving, uh, it's not
usual that you receive at like that.
So he's probably would buy more than that.
Is that you feel Barry Nice helping
people and easy something that really
everyone has to feel it because he,
as I said,
he's very great indemnification
to your life until you're,
you know,
do you,
absolutely.
So it sounds like one thing that you
thought or one incident you thought was
just going to be the one time thing
turned into this whole, you know,
series of events that basically found you.
Yeah,
I get out of my comfort zone and I
thought that I will come back and yeah.
Now you're still going for
the one with I'm doing.
So this is like right now it's my comfort
zone to be, to be a here Moreso fender.
I don't see myself doing something
different, even though that I can,
I mean I have to,
because to be a humorous offenders,
nothing something that actually you have,
do you have a lease in economic
indemnification that, um, so
you have to continue working.
And this is something that I always say
to Kim or resist the defenders if we are
to be calm or human rights offenders,
think about doing it because it's not
that you will receive a payment for that.
So you have to continue
working in what you do and,
and tried to finance
yourself. And, um, uh,
as I said,
I always say that whenever I help people,
I will always receive something
a better from, from life.
That's a perfect segue, um, to Angelita.
Angelita can you tell us a little bit
about partners for human rights and how
your partnership with a fellow came to
be? So my organization, Robert Defcon,
he humorize has been
giving every year for,
this is the 34th here that
we give, uh, these, uh,
annual human rights award that eads
was created to recognize people like,
afraid of,
you know,
the most courageous human rights
offenders from around the world. And, um,
the program that I direct is
precisely a support program within our
organization.
For those that win the award,
the award is an idol only
recognition, uh, eight cells. So,
or offering as an organization to Alfredo
and his organization to really provide
all the support we can, all
the tools we use, uh, no,
or expertise or human resources
or contacts right yet to help,
um,
amplify the voice of
[inaudible] as a network of,
of laureates that, that we have. Um,
and that's, that's what we hope to,
to, to be able to from now on, continue
working very much hand in hand with,
with Alfredo and photo penile,
uh,
knowing that Venezuela right now really
needs the international attention and
the support from, from people
all around the world, uh,
to put it into these,
these situation in this crisis.
And one of the areas that
as an organization we've
been focusing more and more
is the protection of civic space and,
uh,
including of course the basic freedoms
that make civic space possible.
Freedom of expression,
freedom of Association and assembly.
And by partnering with Courageous
Human Rights Offenders, second flow,
we tried to protect those basic rights
because in helping those that are the
front line, like Alfredo putting their
lives at risk, their reputation, no,
and he didn't say so,
but he's attack constantly by him,
by government and by sectors of society
that don't like him being a supportive
of those that are being, uh,
whose rights are being violated.
And by partnering with Alfredo and put
up an avenue salon or we're trying to
lend our support and extend our hand to,
uh,
organizations that really are in,
in,
in the day to day trying to take the
most important and basic freedoms that we
all need,
um,
to really be able to participate
into express ourselves. And,
and, and, and, you know,
have even to the people
that have been detained,
but sometimes they're just
protesting for the basic right of,
of having food under the table,
being able to work or being able
to disagree with the government.
And those rights are being
completely curtail. So again, we,
we aim at supporting organizations that
are doing incredible work just like
[inaudible] and protect that
space that is so important.
I mean those basic freedoms such
as expression and association.
So,
you know,
we are in a very interesting time right
now where there are a lot of causes that
could use support. Um, and
so what was it specifically,
because I know that there
were thousands of applicants.
What was it about unfair though and his
specific organization that led to the
selection of the 2017, uh, Robert F.
Kennedy Foundation, Human Rights Award?
Many reasons. Um, I
fairways definitely the,
the very clear and a unanimous
decision by the jury.
We have an external jury that chooses the,
each year the,
the low and we don't plan.
We saw somebody that is courageous,
that has being able to
choose a different path.
And having had that even carrier has
made and has received the calling of,
of being a human is offender and has um,
yeah,
really fell through. We did. And, um, we,
we also saw it and see that,
um,
ability and the to take it
like the methodology that
is used by my Alfredo and a
up an advantage. This, um,
idea of really creating a network,
um,
it's unending support that goes beyond
just the legal systems but also attends
to all the other aspects of, of uh, needs
of victims of human rights violations.
So he's a very integral approach
and it involves people, uh,
and in your victims and families
of victims and society at large.
So that was one,
one of the many special things then that
had flavor has and his leadership and
also, um, yeah,
using data even though there is no
independence of the judiciary and um,
the, the, the government has
absolute control over everything.
What I've been at and pretty have nine
entirely given up on the rule of law and
know the need to use the law to defend
the basic human rights of people.
But at the same time also use
all these other creative ways,
including social media to
try to get the message out.
So that's another reason why we
thought, um, I couldn't really embodied
the courage and the creativity and
the perseverance that we would look to
recognize with a human rights award.
So we've touched on technology a few
times today and the use of social media to
create awareness on what's going on,
to notify family members and to
even just get the word out. Um,
so last week there was a law passed,
uh,
that gives printed prison sentences up
to 20 years if a post or if something,
uh, on broadcast television or on
the radio is deemed as hateful.
Um, you know, in the wake of
that recent, that recent lot,
how can technology still be used as a
something that can help your organization
and, um, as a human rights
defender in general?
Well,
um,
and I guess also the impact photo
is too,
who will say five,
but do you have to have all
these obstacles since we started?
Um,
does he sell low?
That actually restricts severally
this kind of expressions,
which are geos, expressions, I will say
expressions or message us or whatever.
Yeah.
Against the government because the
government is the ones who buy your leads.
Sorry, human rights. If
you abuse people. Um,
the problem with this law,
I mean they call it a law
against hey toy games.
Um,
but what the problem is that they
don't even explained what does in mean?
I mean, what is, um, a
message that actually,
uh,
you know,
this is included in this law
and it will be sanctioned,
um, or criminalized. You don't
know. So it's very discreet.
It's on the government discretion.
Why when it's a message
against the law or no,
that's a big problem.
But this is our law and new law,
but they already have been detaining
people for Twitter messages. Right now,
for example, there was a guy called, his
name is Victor [inaudible] for example.
These guys be in jail for more than
three years just because of a Twitter
message.
Um,
there is another guy
called Leonel Sanchez.
He was in you still in jail because of
that other being more than nine people
because of social media
using social media.
Um, and they come to your house and
they take you out of your house,
uh,
because well they can find out
where you have sent the message.
So
the important thing is that the whole
world knows about it and they understand
that they're using this loss in order to,
you know,
officialized or legalized in
some way in have to formalize,
I will say, Eh, political persecution.
But this is something that we
are used to it. And, um, um,
well we have to continue doing our
job in there are very objective and,
and um, and the way that we're doing
that we use still need the two.
And of course for the government,
no, but that's why they,
they restrict or media on all freedom of
expression because they don't want the
truth to be known all around the worst.
So that's why it is extremely
important to be here. Um, for example,
uh, I will say this,
companies like Google or,
or international companies
that have the access to,
I will say to people and
that they can tell the truth,
I hope that they can help
countries like Venezuela,
that we are always more
and more restricted. And,
and sometimes it's is important because
I'm totally sure that if you leave
here in the United States or in a free
country, you will say, well come and
why these people are stupid. You know,
why, why these people can be
controlled by a guy or two guys.
Why they don't protest to,
I didn't do things like that where they
don't just go out of the street. Oh,
people have gone out of the street,
made anytimes. But having killed,
having tortured on the, when your song
is being killed, I was 16 years old,
15 years old for example,
this [inaudible], uh,
15 years old boy that was skilled then
you think twice before going out of,
uh, out of trees. So, so this is
important to understand because, um,
and this is also very
important thing to understand.
You cannot take freedom for granted.
If you live in a free country because
you never know when you're going to lose
it.
I used to live in a free country.
I didn't know.
I didn't even imagine that it
will be involved in these issues.
Uh, I didn't even imagine that
will become a humorous offense.
I didn't imagine that will be here at
some point in my life is not general
something I was looking for,
but I'm glad it happened.
And um, that's why he's important, um,
for the whole world to know,
um, you know, for the people to,
to be some kind of interested in,
in human rights and human rights abusers.
And um, in thinking about your
partnership together with,
uh, throughout the Robert
F. Kennedy Foundation,
I guess in thinking of the year ahead,
um,
what's your vision between this
partnership and even the organization?
My vision. Why? Well, for
both of them, um, uh, we, uh,
as we have been growing for open,
Eh,
very much, uh, we're more, as I said,
more than four south and volunteers
are these moment in Venezuela,
a EDC important to what he called twin
tart internationalized for open al.
And the, the, and the message and he
know there's a message, the method,
the methodology that we used [inaudible]
increased the cost of political, of,
of state repression. And I
think this partnership, um,
uh, I have to find out how we will
work together. Yeah. A lot about,
I know that, uh, it is extremely
important, um, to have, uh,
uh,
an NGO or an organization dependent
one that can actually help in Eh,
you know,
pulled in the message
and you know, and the place
where it, where it needs to be,
you know, food and this
and the way that, uh,
we need everyone to know what
is going on and um, you know,
make people interested in,
in what he's going on and actually for
even for our safety and so in some place
in some way because,
uh, when you, as I said,
we work there leg in the darkness
and if you talk about Venezuela,
maybe you will think, well, first of all,
where he's been a sweater in South
America. Okay, let me see. Okay.
And what is happening
there? I mean, yeah. So,
well there is a guy whose name is Alfredo
Romero with an organization that works
in a system, a big theme for the state
repression. So people have been killed,
people are being tortured.
Well three central gate station here in
the United States that actually can in
some way speak or a Lauder
and say that this is going on.
I mean in case something happened to us,
then we have some one here then
at least putting attention,
uh, of what is going on there. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean for us it's, it's,
it's a privilege and it's an
honor and we're really, um,
truthfully very, very, um,
eager to help as much as,
as we can, including there's many tools.
One of them of course he did one video,
all the advocacy work international book.
I see that we can,
we can do around the word bet and what,
why these going on in Venezuela and the
work that for a banana is doing. Um,
we also do international mediation.
We've been cases like
implematic cases that uh,
before international tribunals where,
um,
cases that I representative of a
wider, larger problem. And, uh,
for example, the law, the recent law,
then my spice in Venezuela. It's,
it's,
it's interesting because it's just an
example of one of the tactics that more
and more countries are using repressive
countries where social media was like
another frontier that was not,
it was completely out of control
for repressive governments. And so,
and it's so new also and he's so new,
so they're really by adopting this type
of laws are trying to also control that.
And um, and so it's, it's, you know,
there's a lot of things to do there
even to try to combat these laws.
But there's,
there's many aspects of the work that,
and the tools that we can use together,
um,
including read international mechanisms,
then targeted advocacy that
we really look forward to,
to work together on and just put the
message out and continue calling the
attention of, of, of the world
and what's going on in Venezuela.
So I have one more question before
I open it up to Q and. A. Um,
so for the people here, for the
people that will watch this, uh,
for anybody that's interested, how can
people help? How can people get involved?
Um, you know, being in the
United States, what can you do?
What can you do to help?
We incorporate everyone to our
network so everyone can be part,
can be a member of four opener so they
can register for open al.com and actually
this is extreme,
very important because it's what I say,
even if you work one minute a month,
I said Boland tear doing that,
you know,
saying something about what is going
on even if you just worked two hours.
Um, I dunno, participate in, in a,
in a an assembly or in a forum that
we do eat is extremely important.
So, um, as I said,
everyone is important here.
I mean,
and we train people to become
powerful or organizations.
So that's some very
important thing because if,
if you are registered in our organization,
then we know where you
are and we can some way,
Eh, send information
and, and because he's,
I mean, he's extremely important
to understand what is going on.
This is the most important thing. How
you, I will say not translated in the,
you know,
the judge did not use the language is
how to make people understand what,
what does in mean to live in a country
that the freedom has been a lost even the
children. I mean we
incorporate 14 years old, uh,
boys or girls bogus and I
listened to them exhibited from,
well I will say that in order for
anyone to understand what you say,
you have to talk to a 13 years old boy.
That's the way that you have to,
that people can understand what you're
saying is difficult, but it is important.
So that's the way, the best way to, to,
to support what we do. Um, and um,
for example,
as you know,
I'm not talking about lawyers of course,
not just students or,
or intellectuals I'm talking
about is singers, about artist,
about DC 16 year platform, every, no,
but everything is extremely
important. I used for example, music.
I'm a musician,
so use music in order to sing and some
time to explain where I'm doing with that
with a songs. And when,
whenever I, for example,
I publish a song either in Youtube,
whatever singing,
I will get more views that just talking
about a state repression and you know,
all the technicalities of these, of people
that are being tortured or whatever.
So everyone can help just,
I always ask people to register to become
part of our organization and I'm sure
that they will do something very good
for people in Venezuela and also all
around the world where,
where governments and um,
dictators actually have
the control of people.
And I needs to control people with
repression or to keeping power.
Google is known for having some of the
most talented people on technical field
and
communications field. They think that
putting that talent also in getting,
coming up with ideas, particularly on
when it comes to getting the message out.
Um, uh, securities also big thing,
not only for, you know, a fair bit.
All the people in the network,
why they're doing what photo is doing
is documenting human rights abuses that
comes at a high risk.
So anything that can help
do that work in a safer way,
in a more secure way, in a
more mainstream way. Um, it's,
it's always going to be welcome.
Even Venezuela and, and,
and in other places in the
world where, uh, but in,
in this specific case of Venezuela is,
especially now with the additional
challenges that are being created by the
government,
really disseminating information.
That's also something where these,
the brains that we have here,
I'm sure it can be very,
very useful.
Just very quick. It was, um,
also another story bearing tourist in
order to understand how, for example,
people in the working help and again,
daily and what is going on and to increase
in the cost of political repression
that they call the political
cost of repression. Just once,
about one year ago, there was,
um, a woman that was detained,
uh, she was protesting or
whatever and she was, um, she was,
her name was Joseph alleine show.
She was sustained actually,
and she was taken to,
um, to a military base.
And these guy, from
what she's told me, uh,
this military officer was starting,
it started touching her on,
she was with her like in a,
in an office in his office and somebody
started knocking the other door.
There was a soldier or whatever,
and this guy is a stand up,
very quick stop touching her.
And then the guy came back to the office,
I start yelling and took her and to
her to whatever place, I don't know.
And she said, why are you, why? Well,
because there's social media is with your
picture, with your name. I'm married.
Then we were the ones that were actually
publishing pictures of her and their
name on her name. And so this is extremely
important. So this is the only way.
Sometimes you can not totally sure.
And she says that,
that we held her, I mean if, if we,
if we were in their publishing
the pictures, I'm so,
I'm sure she will be, um,
raped. So, um, it's
extreme important. I mean,
just if you mentioned something
in social media network,
whatever he could, he
could save a life. So, uh,
that's how you can help. For
example, I will give you,
I know their idea is something that I,
I don't care because whoever can do
it and Google is a place. For example,
I have thought on a map of big
teams of repression the world.
So there isn't a map. So how many
political prisoners are in? They were,
nobody knows it. I know I didn't make
country because we have a register.
So it's important to know where are the
big teams of repression or around there
so people can actually put their names
so that the whole world knows there is
like a map or so
something's happening here,
something's happening there and
Google is a great platform to do that.
Now I want to open it up for questions.
Does anyone,
does anyone have any questions
on either side?
We can start with you.
Sure. Hi. Well thank you for everything.
So global are also data driven company
and I see you're looking at a lot at you,
at your data. I'm just curious,
how have you seen trends?
I mean with number of cases,
number of repressions and things it
change or has it only gold and on par.
Has there been any change?
I mean I'm interested about it.
Yeah, this is, this is a very
important question. Again, we,
how we work or how I analyze everything.
I analyze this as a, as a cost,
as a political cost benefit analysis.
That's it off the repression.
So we are the organization that actually
shows the list of political prisoners
in Venezuela,
just to give you an idea.
So they use what I have called
the revolving door effect.
So when they incarcerate some and they
release and others and they incarcerate
the recent others.
So I always said that there'd been more
than 11 south and 900 whatever political
detainees. But so there've
been affected. I mean the,
the intimidation effect
is really important. So
everyone is being intimidated.
So everyone is a big team.
So she told me that if one of
our families was a big thing,
so they called us and you can see all
that as well as all around the world even
telling me the same thing.
So in order to increase the political
costs we have showed how many political
prisoners are.
So for example,
before April, 2017, before the,
the last broadest mass processes started,
they were a one south,
117 political prisoners monthly.
If you see our statistics,
there were 100 every month,
there were not the same. We're 100,
you know, with uh, uh, political, uh,
with a revolving door effect
around talking about it in
July because of protest,
the number of political prisoners
increased to six and 76.
And we started saying that
there were 676 right now.
After that I started,
uh, we started, uh, Eh,
Eh, sending the list of political
prisoners to the Oi Aes,
to the Organization of American States
in order for them to certify it at least,
and to verify it, at least not
for the government to say, well,
where are the political prisoners?
Where they here? So the OAS has,
it has the least. So we have it here.
So we have the names on everything.
We'll re now the government called dose.
Actually send me a letter asking for the
least of people that had been detained
in a bile int eh actions or whatever.
This is the least of political prisoners.
So I answer the letter,
I sent another letter, um, saying, okay,
here's the list of political prisoners.
Actually they use the lease and they
went to all [inaudible] centers.
Some of the prisoners
centers, actually the, the,
the number of political prisoners
have decreased to 342 is a,
is the last one.
So every week they had
decreased the number two about
in about 1120 or whatever.
So they have to go again to
the 100, Eh, Eh, you know,
number.
And this is important because this is
how you increase the political cost.
This is how you do because the government,
they are not,
they don't want to have a, you know,
one south and political prisoners,
they don't want to have 600 political
business. Well, they don't one,
it's not that they don't want to have it.
They want to have it because it's an
intimidation effects or they don't want
people to protests or they, they want
people to say, okay, if I go to protests,
they haven't gone to jail.
So I prefer not to protest or I'm being
killed or whatever. So they, they,
they don't care about, uh, about, uh,
incarcerating people by data one the world
to know they have political prisoners
so shall the ones who are showing that.
So that's why I was telling you about
this map because if a country in the world
knows that the mat that they,
the map shows that they have 100
political prisoners, they will like,
they will better not to
have anyone if nobody knows.
For example,
in Egypt,
I was talking once to a human rights
defender there and I asked her,
how many political prisoners
do you have in Egypt?
I'm talking about Egypt because Egypt
is not, he's not a socialist country.
Cause you know,
it doesn't matter if you're a
socialist or capitalist or whatever.
It doesn't matter.
Political prisoners or repression
can happen in a socialist country,
in a capitalist country. And
she told me, I didn't know,
I dunno, 10,000, 20,000.
And she asked me and I said,
we have bought that, that, that the number
specific number. And then I realized,
okay, this is how you, uh,
these,
the way,
the methodology to release political
prisoners or to stop repression or to
decrease the state repression. And, well,
that's why I think, I don't
know if I answered your
question specifically, but I,
I think, uh, that's, that's the best,
the most important thing
that actually we do.
Thanks for your question.
So I just want to end on actually
a quote from Robert F. Kennedy. Um,
it reads,
it's from the numberless diverse acts
of courage and belief that human history
is shaped.
So thank you both for your courage and
thank you for everything that you do.
And thank you for being here today.
Thank you all for coming.